mr. cook you're almost up are you ready
good good really gonna need you to stick
to the script on this well I'm the CEO
of Apple Willis I'm not gonna do
anything stupid please stop comparing me
to Steve Jobs oh but nobody's comparing
you to Steve Jobs okay I just want you
to focus on the products and please
stick to the script okay
you're on in three we're gonna forget
they ever heard the name Steve Jobs
[Applause]
thing that I'm gonna do is tio
ts throw out the scripts now I'm
supposed to come out here and tell you
about some bull new iPhone pad pod dick
[ __ ]
you've seen it out of it out of that
boring
now let's sit this table right here
let's say it's Bill Gates huh
[Applause]
what I'm talking about and let's say
that this is our competitors new
smartphone
[Applause]
this is one of our competitors new
e-book reader huh what about that
like Wayne
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
we want the system
[Applause]
you can't do that they haven't been
tested yet this device will allow you to
teleport anywhere on the planet check
this out let's see Steve Jobs do that
you